La volta al món a peu, dia 276, són les set i mitja i començo a caminar, la família s'ha anat ja a l'escola, tots uniformats, com podeu veure ens han fet una foto, molt bé, molt simpàtics, molt majos, m'han donat esmorzar també.
He dormit força bé, força bé, i ja he dit que aquest matí ja fa un pèl de fresqueta, eh? Avui és 1 de setembre, dimarts, i winter is coming, winter is coming.
Bé, una cosa que no vaig explicar ahir, que és important, és que em fan mal els peus, especialment el peu esquerre m'ha sortit una llaga, no una llaga, una butllofa.
Ahir la vaig punxar, vaig drenar el líquid, feia molt de temps que no en sortia cap butllofa, eh? No sé de què serà, tinc dues teories, una, el terreny ja no és tan pla i tan guai com els altres dies, però això tampoc no hauria suposat ampliar perquè he caminat per terrenys tipus pista i tal.
I la segona teoria és que l'amortiguació de l'escoca ja està bastant donada, sí.
Eh, no, no, no ho sé, no ho sé. I m'ha sortit aquí al davant i a l'altre peu no m'ha sortit butllofa, però tinc dolor i una molt, molt, molt petiteta ferida a la mateixa zona.
No sé, potser que siguin els mitjons, també. Avui els he canviat, m'ho he posat uns altres. No ho sé, potser els meus peus simplement necessiten descans.
Demà descansaré, demà no camino, però avui sí, toquen 43 quilòmetres.
Doncs, bueno, és una bona hora per fer tants quilòmetres. A veure si els meus peus aguanten o no.
Avui costarà, eh. Avui costarà, són les deu i mitja. Fan mal als peus i sento fatigat.
Ho veig moltes vegades, eh, però quan el cos sap que pararàs d'aquí una estona, avui, quan acabi el dia, és com que costa més, sempre. L'última part de l'excursió, de la ruta, sempre costa més.
Ara estic aquí a una vila i allà hi ha un supermercat, comprenc alguna cosa i m'asseuré a descansar i ja està.
Doncs venia per aquí caminant, cansat, com us deia aquests dies, i m'he trobat un ciclista en Mingi, que és coreà, i dic, bueno, serà un altre ciclista que està fent el Pamir.
No, no, no, no. Can I sit?
He actually has a great record of cycling.
So, can you tell us what were your trips before this one?
Okay, so my first trip was across Canada by bicycle.
So I bought that bicycle in Canada.
And after that I go down to the, all the way to Ushuaia.
From Canada to Ushuaia?
Yeah.
In Argentina, yes.
Patagonia.
Yeah.
Amazing.
And next trip was from Cape Town, south of Africa, to Nairobi.
Wow.
So...
And this is the third trip from Japan to Portugal.
Not bad, not bad.
What was your favorite country to ride in all your trips?
I think this time actually I like here, Pamir.
You like it here?
Yeah, the Baltang and all the Pamir way.
But before, my favorite was Patagonia.
Yeah, from Santiago to Ushuaia.
It was crazy.
The Austral...
I think it's the name.
Caràcter austral.
Yeah.
Great, great.
What was your least favorite country?
Africa.
Malawi.
Did you have any problems like, because, I don't know, Europeans think about Africa
like it's dangerous or something?
Africa is tired.
It's dangerous also, because a lot of animals, lions, elephants, but most tired thing is
people.
People?
Yeah.
Every child and adult and children chase me and begging money.
Yeah, that is also tired and sometimes, I don't know, every day was difficult to find
a spot to camping because people are everywhere and...
You try to hide every day, yes.
I have tried to hide from the road, from the village.
So you've eaten a lot of different food from different countries.
What was your favorite food?
Mexico.
Which country?
Mexico, yes.
I understand.
And the worst?
Africa food.
Was it like, like, rice all day, or...?
Yeah, they had a rice, but normally, their normal food, you know, shima?
No.
The shima is from the corn powder and they mix with the water and like this.
Mm.
They eat it with the rice.
They don't taste nothing.
Mm.
And they eat with the vegetable or meat.
Mm-hmm.
But the problem is they have no, like, a refrigerator.
Mm.
So...
Yeah.
No, the food is not very fresh.
Okay.
And I had many times the food poisoned in Africa.
It was terrible.
I had it here in Tajikistan.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's also very common.
And what do you eat?
And what else?
Best people?
Like, the most kind or the most hospitable?
I think Argentina.
Wow.
Surprising.
And Mexico.
And Mexico, eh?
Yeah.
Okay.
No, no.
I said surprising because now there's a lot of controversy.
Argentinians, but yeah.
Okay, okay.
And maybe the least welcoming people?
I'm sorry.
Africa.
Wow.
You love the trip in Africa, actually.
I was sorry.
I'm sorry.
I was so tired when I ride in Africa.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
But people are nice, but I don't know, they always begging money.
It's so tired.
Makes me sometimes annoying.
Sometimes, they throw the rock to me.
Ah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's dangerous.
What's the weight on your luggage?
Did you weight it?
Do you know how much you carry?
Yeah.
I think the water and food is 40, but it depends the...
Forty?
Forty kilogram.
Wow.
Yeah.
Counting the bike or not counting the bike?
Include bicycle.
Include the bike.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, good luck.
Thank you.
And I hope you have no much cold in Russia, because you're going to Russia and the winter
is coming.
Yeah, I know.
I have to cross the big mountain, Russia to Georgia.
The Caucasus.
Yeah.
I have to cross in winter, maybe December.
Wow.
Yes.
Ahir explosions, avui tirs, no ho vull gravar però a darrere d'aquest turonet
està l'exèrcit de Tajikistan fent pràctiques de tir, o això m'ha semblat.
Hi ha una espècie de muntícula amb sacs de sorra que estan disparant allà,
hi havia com unes 20 persones o alguna cosa així.
Bé, les 2 i 20, 24 quilòmetres, costa, avui costa, em fan mal els peus,
no només aquesta part que tinc la llaga sinó en general el peu,
no estic trepitjant de manera normal, estic com, no sé, suposo que intentant evitar
que em faci mal aquí a zona, llavors ja trepitjo rar, llavors ja em fan mal altres parts del peu.
Cosset afganès.
Avui molt verd, eh? Avui molt verd, avui és l'últim dia que veuré l'Afganistan
i me n'alegro, perquè ahir vaig tenir inquietud amb allò de les explosions i dic, ja està, ja està.
Potser és l'últim cop que veig l'Afganistan a la meva vida.
No? S'escolten els tirs? Estan una mica lluny, eh?
Seguim encara gairebé 20 quilòmetres més fins a la ciutat, fins a Jorok.
M'acabo de trobar la senyal de mines antipersona, que no estiguin netejant això de mines, els militars, eh?
Podria ser. Bueno, voleu que expliqui això, les mines antipersones?
Doncs si no voleu és igual, perquè ho explico igualment.
Tajikistan es va independentitzar de la...
...de la Unió Soviètica el 1991.
L'any següent, el 1992, es va esclatar una guerra civil que va durar 5 anys fins al 1997.
Quan hi ha una guerra, sempre volem saber quins són els bons i quins són els dolents, no? Per posicionar-nos.
No, Enric, però és que a les guerres no hi ha bons ni dolents.
Sí, ja, però anem a ser sincers, no sigui hipòcrites.
Tothom intenta veure de quin mànal...
...el bàndol ha d'estar, no? Bé, doncs en un bàndol teníem els oficialistes, els que controlaven l'estat, que, bueno, doncs eren gent de Tajikistan, tal,
i també estaven recolzats per Rússia, Kyrgyzstan, Kazakstan, algun altre país que no recordo, i la ONU.
I de l'altre bàndol, doncs, estaven els insurgents, gent d'aquesta zona del país, el Pamir,
i l'Iran, els talibans i Al-Qaeda.
Que no cal dir res més, no?, de qui eren els bons i qui eren els dolents.
Doncs, bueno, va durar, sobretot, la part forta va ser un any, va acabar cinc anys després i el total de morts van ser 50.000, que és molt, que és molt.
I res, doncs, van guanyar els bons.
Gràcies.
I res, doncs, va durar, sobretot, la part forta va ser un any, va acabar cinc anys després i el total de morts van ser 50.000, que és molt.
Ostres, i com és que no tens fills, tal, com és que no tens dona, hauries de tenir dona, és que Déu, doncs, bueno, ja m'ho imagineu, no?, que Déu és com que el que vol pels homes i dones és que tinguin fills, etc, etc, etc.
I jo, sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, avui costarà, eh? És la segona, tercera vegada que ho dic, ja? Avui costarà.
Actualització a les 4 i mitja, ja porto 30 km però encara me'n queden 12 i mig.
Això són 3 hores ben bones. Costarà avui, costarà.
Actualització a les 5 i mitja. Buf! De cop i volta s'ha girat un vent. Jo crec que és perquè la vall és molt ampla ara. Quin vent!
I atenció també, novetat, he vist, fa un mes que estic en aquest país, he vist per primer cop una persona tèxica de Teguistán fent esport.
Era una noia, no sé com es diu.
No ho sé, tindria uns, no ho sé, 18 anys, no ho sé, no ho sé.
I estava fent running, running per aquí, per la carretera del Pamir.
Sí, sí, m'ha semblat curiós. Primer cop en un mes.
Bueno, ja porto 35 km, doncs quedaran uns 8 o així. Bueno, potser una mica menys.
Actualització a les 6 i mitja. Ja estic a les afores de Jorok, però encara queden 3 km per l'hotel.
Però bueno, només 3 km.
Bueno, hi ha uns que fa dies que em pregunteu el preu de la gasolina, no?
Doncs he vist una benzinera i surt d'això.
O sigui, per començar, sorprenent.
A Europa tenim gasolina de 98 i 95 octanats, crec que es diu, no?
Que és la qualitat, la puresa, no?, de la gasolina, crec.
Aquí venen de 92 octanats.
Bueno, doncs mira, és el que hi ha.
I el preu doncs heu d'agafar això i multiplicar-ho per 0,9.
O, més fàcil, dividir-ho per 10, encara que no seria tan exacte.
Però tal, per tant, 1,3 euros més o menys al litre.
Que, bueno, clar, no sé quins sols tenen aquí, però imagino que molt baixos.
Hello.
I bueno, doncs són això i mitja.
He de dir que cada cop es fa de nit més aviat, cosa que ja sabíem.
Però la velocitat amb la que es fa de nit més aviat és molt gran, eh?
Fins fa 4 dies, potser literalment 4 dies o 5 dies,
se n'anava el sol a les 7.
I ara ja se'n va a les 7 menys quart.
Clar, jo estic caminant cap a l'est, i a la vegada,
cada cop hi ha menys joves de llum, no? Però...
Bueno, això em treu marge de cada els propers dies.
Però bueno, tu, és igual, farem com sigui.
Sortirem d'aquest país com sigui.
La set de la tarda és quan he arribat.
Habitació enorme.
Bueno, m'han obgradejat.
Suposo que aquesta estava lliure avui.
I al final les he sortit malament,
perquè just després d'abonar-me a l'habitació han vingut 4 americans, crec.
I clar, no hi havia lloc per ells.
Perquè jo m'he quedat l'habitació triple.
Que tampoc l'he demanat, però bueno.
Està molt bé, l'habitació és molt gran.
M'agraden les habitacions grans.
L'aigua està bé.
No hi ha aire acondicionat.
Però bueno, com veieu, té vistes al riu.
Llavors passa l'aire.
Però crec que demà al matí, o sigui demà durant el dia,
pots fer calor.
Però bueno, tinc un ventilador.
Està bé, està bé.
Un dia de descans.
Era l'habitació amb bany privat més barata de la ciutat.
Ja està.
Quant m'ha costat?
65 euros dos nits.
Ja us dic que Tajikistan no és barat en aquest sentit.
Què més?
M'he gastat 5 euros més.
Només, de moment.
Per tant, 70 euros.
I 43,3 quilòmetres que han sigut fàcils.
En realitat han sigut fàcils avui.
Però han sigut dolorosos.
I m'ha costat.
Ja ho sabeu com m'ha costat.
He parlat avui amb...
Ja ho veig.
Amb 4 persones.
La família.
Més el...
Més el xapas aquell.
I...
I refrescos 3.
Avui he menjat molt sucre.
No tinc gana.
Crec que no...
No baixo ja a sopar.
Guardo energies per l'esmorzar demà, que aquest lloc té esmorzar inclòs.
Aquí et pregunten a quina hora vols l'esmorzar.
Vull dir, no és un bufet, sinó que te'l serveixen ahir, te'l posen a la taula.
Està molt bé.
Doncs res a tu.
Demano ja vídeo.
Però clar, si us heu fixat, vaig dos dies retreçat amb els vídeos.
No és un bufet, sinó que te'l serveixen ahir, te'l posen a la taula.
Està molt bé.
Doncs res a tu.
Demano ja vídeo.
Però clar, si us heu fixat, vaig dos dies retreçat amb els vídeos.
Per tant, per vosaltres, si tot va bé i tinc internet, demà sí que tindreu vídeo.
Llavors tornarem a estar actualitzats a un dia de delay només.
Fins que torni a passar el mateix, que tornarà a passar d'aquí poc, que no tinc internet
i no pugui pujar vídeos.
Llavors hi haurà uns dies de delay.
Però és un bufet.
No és un bufet.
Sí, que tindreu vídeo.
Llavors tornarem a estar actualitzats a un dia de delay només.
Fins que torni a passar el mateix, que tornarà a passar d'aquí poc, que no tinc internet
i no pugui pujar vídeos.
Llavors hi haurà uns dies que no podeu veure el vídeo i tal i tal.
Pero bueno, i no ho feu com l'última vegada que em vau enviar 40 mil missatges de endarrere
que et passarà alguna cosa.
Calma, calma.
Doncs diria que ja està, senyors.
Vaig a dutxar-me i a descansar.
Bona nit.
Fins demà!